You know what I love? that all episodes of your show Youth and Consequences is coming to YouTube Red on March 7th?
You know me, but do you know what else I love? shameless self-promotion? Youth and Consequences YouTube Red March 7th
oh girl thank you for the plug but seriously i also really love practising self-care by getting tattoos with my best friend on valentine's day
-off screen- happy valentine's dayyy, oh it looks great
-off screen- getting there
it's happening
I'm trying so hard not to look like I'm in pain
does it hurt?
yeah, I mean it feels good but it hurts
one thing I really wanted to do this year was to take care of myself but when i was like sitting down and thinking like
okay what does this actually look like
All i could come up with was like go get a massage once a month and take yourself out to dinner and a movie
once a week or something, but as I've been living out the year i'm trying
to be very mindful of like okay actually like take care of yourself and treat yourself like your own child
i've noticed that self-care is about
so much more than just taking myself out on a date
Self-care is doing things that people don't necessarily agree with like one thing I do now is I don't go out if I don't want to
even if I've clicked attending on Facebook, even if I told the person I would be there I know I have a tendency
towards being a workaholic and if i'm exhausted and my body knows it, I listen to that and I bail
because sometimes i just need to stay at home and recharge by like journaling or drawing or just
vegging out in front of the tv
(ahh, I needed this)
I've also been forcing myself, to be really healthy to a very annoying degree like by going
to the gym and eating healthy vegan meals all year and even if it's not really fun you force yourself
to do it because you know what's gonna help in the long term manage all of your
anxieties and depression
I've cut out unhealthy people who don't give a shit about my well-being
I've quit stand-up and improv all together to focus on other artistic pursuits and when people ask me how I am, I tell them
terrible
- Okay
- how are you?
- not terrible
- oh that's cool
I don't necessarily tell them all the details but i also don't feel the need to lie
for the sake of making regular chitchat, if you're gonna ask me how I am you're gonna know how i am
And I've come to accept things about myself like that I'm hella extra that I'm assertive with the capability to be aggressive
and I will always love
Harassing my friends for their opinions on my scripts and my songs and my art even if it's 1am and they just got home
hell i even come to love things about myself that normally i agonize about
daaaaammmnnn girl
yo boobs looking hella smart today
and self-care for your life may look completely different, maybe you're the kind of person who needs to force yourself
to go to parties or social events because you know that's what you need or it means taking a day or two off of the gym
to completely rest or adopting a couple of cats because you're a responsible mature adult who's ready
to give love and receive love with beautiful furry children
Whatever self-care means to you incorporate it into your daily life not just as like a once a month or once a week occasion
Really come from the mindset that you're going to take care of yourself because if we don't who will
I'm Anna Akana stay right here for a sponsored message
Thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring today's episode. Squarespace has beautiful award-winning templates
not to mention their all-in-one platform so there's no installs, patches or upgrades ever
they also have 24-hour customer service so if you really want to tell someone about all your great
qualities they'll be there to listen, they offer a simple and unique set
of experience if you don't have a domain name and they're good for any kind of website whether you're an artist, a photographer
or you just want to make a fan tribute website of yourself. Go to Squarespace.com to start your free trial today
and use the offer code ANNA for 10% off at checkout